Ashley's having a party tonight do you
guys mind if I go what time will you be
home Ashley's mom said I can spend the
night you must be brave it's nice to
meet you mrs. Anderson call me Jackie
we've lost our little girl alright girls
my back it's where the real party's up
move everybody I find you very
attractive
alright boy let's go get a drink I think
I'm gonna go to Beverly Hills Edith
Chavez
these guys don't really look like they
should be driving mister mrs. Thompson
your daughter sustained some serious
injuries mrs. Anderson you are hereby
charged with the following crimes count
one providing minors with alcohol count
two contributing to the delinquency of a
minor and count three in the voluntary
manslaughter because mrs. Anderson has
no criminal record the court will grant
her bail at this juncture I need to go
over there vigilante justice he came
here to kill ash
something from him tell me you didn't
have anything to do with that but let my
emotions get the best of me I will not
let this destroy me
[Music]
we're tracing the weapon back to the
house and you're free to go make sure
you go to prison for life
you